I'm obvious of Asylum and today we're
going to talk about designing and
building metric trees uh look this is a
topic I love uh if you if you pull the
string on my back I'll go for hours uh
fortunately fortunately for you guys
unfortunately for me we only have a half
hour so we're not going to be able to
talk about everything I would like to
talk about we're actually going to bound
this mostly to the design piece and less
the building piece I think they're
they're definitely going to be other
opportunities to get into implementation
details including actually after this
I'm recording a podcast in the office
hours room so I hope you stick around
for some of those conversations as we
kind of get into more the technical
details uh for the purposes of this
conversation I'm just here to beat you
over the head with the notion that
metric trees are cool and important and
transformative because the reality is
nothing we're going to talk about today
is that revolutionary it's not
mind-blowing what's revolutionary is
taking it seriously what's the
Revolutionary is actually taking the
implication seriously and orienting data
teams and companies around this idea
which is significantly more rare so with
that Preamble out of the way we'll start
so we're going to start with the
question of why and for our purposes
here we're actually not going to start
with why uh we're not going to start
with why metric trees directly we're
going to start with a a more a more
fundamental more existential question
for for this group here which is uh wide
data what's the point of what's the
point of this data stuff anyway why are
we here on adult spring break for you
know the past couple of days and look my
background is I I run data teams and I
run growth teams I do this I've done
this for the past couple of decades as
uh as a leader that actually builds up
those functions advisor investor
consultant Etc through the process I've
seen intimately seen hundreds of
companies hundreds of data teams and my
answer to this question is uh that most
of the value of data 90 of the value of
data for 90 of companies is really
analytics specific right it's really
just answering these four questions what
happened why did it happen what's going
to happen next and what should we do
about it right or what should we do to
bring it into effect this is this is it
and I know this is an AI focused
conference data Science Focus conference
as well but Dems the breaks for most
companies this is where the bulk of the
value is actually harvested
to the extent that a data team can look
at itself can introspect on the work
that's happening in that team can look
at the the tools and the vendors that
that team uses and can draw a straight
line a clear line to being able to
answer these questions that team is
probably creating value and it's
creating value efficiently to the extent
that that team you know looks at its
Tools looks at the work it's doing and
can only draw an opaque line or an
indirect line to answering these kinds
of questions that team is probably not
creating value and it's certainly not
creating value efficiently
and so if you believe that as I do then
look the fundamental question for data
teams is how do we ensure that we are
always oriented restructure reposition
in the company to be answering these
questions these four questions uh easily
quickly and often so low latency low
friction and with high frequency right
and this is you know with all the data
teams that I run with all the you know
folks I advise uh this is the kind of
the fundamental ethos question for for
data teams to Grapple with
my answer to that is uh well tldr
spoiler alerts metric trees right but my
answer to that starts by thinking about
an organization as just a system right
all organizations right non-profit
for-profit whatever industry you're in
all organizations really are just ways
of translating inputs so you know
physical capital human capital
intellectual Capital running it through
the meat grinder of a company and
popping out the other side some kind of
value denominated assets right
predominantly cash that's really all a
company is that's really all any kind of
organization is now because we are
especially here quantitatively minded
folk we look at uh we look at a function
that translates inputs into outputs and
we look we see a function and when we
see that function we see a formula and
just as businesses are all really just
input output systems uh if I didn't know
anything about a set of companies other
than their fundamental form formula that
describes how that company translates
inputs and outputs I'd be able to
identify that company right this is
really the fingerprint of a company the
unique identifier for a company is how
that unique company translates inputs
into outputs and that unique fingerprint
is basically you know for us we can
think about it as a fundamental formula
uh if we peer into that formula what
makes these formulas different from
company to company those formulas have
basically three parts right there are
metrics so metrics are uh business facts
about how value in that company is
created how it's captured uh or how it's
uh it's transferred or lost uh
relationships that tie those metrics
together that try those business facts
together and weights and weights that
Express uh the significance of different
relationships as they relate to the
outputs right that's all this kind of
formula notion is
and if we take a step back uh you know
if we understand that formula and we
understand if we understand that formula
that's all the company is if we really
could you know uh in a vacuum draw out
this fundamental formula for a company
we would understand everything about
that company and if we understand
everything about that company then we
are able to answer those questions right
we are able to answer the descriptive
analytics the predictive the
prescriptive uh uh the inferential uh
and uh do those with low latency low
friction and high frequency right and so
the goal for us then is uh to understand
this sure but like I said this is not a
revolutionary concept right I think
everyone in here has probably heard of
the notion of fundamental formula or a
business equation Etc that's not what's
revolutionary what's revolutionary is
taking it seriously because how many
companies do you know that actually
Orient their company to words operating
understanding this fundamental formula
and that brings me to kind of how I see
the Mandate of data team when I run data
teams this is how I position data teams
the raison Detra for my data teams and
my growth teams is your job is to help
the company Define understand evolve and
operationalize your growth model when
companies talk about data strategy well
this is actually the most important data
strategy how is that data team and how
is that company using its data to
understand its growth model now I'm
using growth model here for the first
time right the only difference between a
growth model and a fundamental formula
as I see it is that the growth model is
what takes that formula and reifies it
right so it takes that formula and makes
it trackable over time engageable
interactable you know Etc it's what
makes that fundamental formula real and
the Mandate of a growth team of a data
team rather is to make that growth model
real
okay Enter metric trees so uh a metric
tree is look a metric tree is nothing
more than just a logical representation
of a growth model right uh we know the
distinction between conceptual and
logical and physical models uh you know
everyone here that works with data uh
for a growth model uh which again we
mentioned was physically reified for our
growth model the kind of The Logical
precursor is this notion of a metric
tree uh and this both supports the
creation of a growth model but it also
is an ergonomic way to present and
consume what that growth model is
actually telling you and a metric tree
is really just uh outputs
uh inputs and uh relationships and we
should recognize that these are
basically what we called out as the
parts of the fundamental formula too
right metrics relationships and weights
so that's basically what a tree is right
so now the question is uh okay great how
do we go about building this tree right
we're not focused so much on actually
reifying the growth model in this
conversation but how do we go about
actually constructing this tree for our
business or for my specific
organizational unit
there's really four steps uh to making
metric trees we're going to keep this
pretty simple step number one you're
going to Define North Stars step number
two you're going to recursively uh break
down inputs uh step number three you
layer additional inputs and step number
four uh you add metadata you hang
metadata onto onto this tree and so
we're gonna paste through those one by
one
uh so from the top uh so North Stars
right the notion of North Star North
Stars gets a lot of chatter uh a lot of
NBA speak around this notion of North
Stars I'm just going to cut right to the
chase on how I see the notion of a North
star these are the most top level most
high order metrics in the company and
what I like to say is they are the
metrics from which all other metrics
derive their legitimacy if another
metric does not point to the North Star
it's an illegitimate metric there are
three types of North Stars uh customer
value financial and strategic and this
is true at the company level but it's
also true at an organizational level
right any kind of organizational subunit
you're looking at so customer value a
customer value nor star is simply a
North star that is denominated in terms
of customer value right
the footprint of value that a product or
service is creating for for end
customers most commonly used in truly
product oriented technology denominated
product LED companies the North Star for
you know a bi tool might be number of
views on on dashboards the North Star
for chat GPT in terms of customer value
might be a number of prompts that are
successfully returned right but measure
of the footprint of customer value with
the notion with the belief that if you
take care of customer value the score
takes care of itself right
Financial North Star is that score that
takes care of itself it's how we measure
that score it's how we keep that score
and that these are p l realities right
these are capital inflows or capital
outflows from the p l that Express uh
how we have captured or expended value
in the process of generating what we
generate as a company strategic North
stars are less common they're less
common because most companies are not
strategic it's as simple as that
strategic North stars are representative
of uh not Direct Value not direct
Financial realities but steps along the
way that Define the why we win for a
company right this could look like
strategic Market expansion this could
look like modes this could look like
Network effects it could look like
things that are very indirect from the
other two types of North Stars but are
still essential for long-term value
accretion
so uh our first step is to pick a North
star for our organization our unit right
so metric trees in the wild usually
start with dollars so we're going to
start with dollars too
um so for our example here we're going
to start with simple Revenue
uh step two and three were both about
input metrics if you recall I said step
two was you're going to recursively
Define inputs uh step three is you're
going to layer on additional inputs why
am I distinguishing between uh inputs
and two steps uh it's because there are
two types of inputs output metrics all
decompose into two types of input
metrics there are what I call components
and what I call inputs
uh so components this is step two right
when I say recursively decompose your
metrics that's step two components are
just mathematical identities they are
definitionally true right revenue is
customers times ASP that is what that is
the definition of Revenue it's a
definition of customer it's the
definition of ASP these are how
fundamentally these metrics relate to
one another customers is at least in our
reductive example leads times win rate
right these are how they're
fundamentally defined uh how they're
fundamentally oriented they will always
be true because they're True by
definition
once you recursively go down this chain
so actually we're defining our North
Star we're recursively going down the
chain we're defining we're defining uh
when we run out of what I call uh the
metric vocabulary when we run out of the
metric vocabulary to continue to
decompose uh those metrics that are left
are our Leaf metrics and we do not
proceed uh the step three is that we're
going to layer on influences uh
influences are contingent relationships
right these are temporally contingent
they're empirically derived they're not
true by definition they're true as
empirical realities uh speed to lead
here for those of you who aren't
familiar with the B2B model uh B2B sales
model is uh has this notion of you know
you have inbound leads that come in
speed Elite is basically how quickly I
get at that lead right how quickly does
an SDR show up at your doorstep and ask
you to uh sign on the dotted line or
talk to an AE uh speed delete is an
empirical metric it is at the
relationship between speed the lead and
win rate has a certain relationship
today it might have a different
relationship tomorrow it looks different
across different companies it is
temporally contingent it's empirically
derived it is not by definition true
it's mediated by by other kinds of
amorphous and unstable relationships
right so uh the step three is really
great we have all of these components
now we're going to go hang these
influences we might know influences to
be sure right we might absolutely know
that speed delete is an influence we
might not know influences these might
also just be pure hypotheses but we're
going to layer both of these influences
and hang them onto our tree as step
three
uh step four is we're gonna add metadata
now uh you know I'm a big graph guy you
know if you look carefully this is
actually just a graph right it's a graph
of nodes and edges when we talk about
metadata we're going to hang metadata on
both nodes and edges right on edges
there are two important types of
metadata we want to be adding that is
strength how strong is the relationship
between one metric and another and
confidence how certain are we about that
relationship uh
for uh inputs for these for these nodes
we're going to be hanging what we would
kind of colloquially call as slices
right like if I want to understand win
rate I would look at win rate by X by y
by Z what are those X's y's and Z's how
would I reason about what a metric is
and how that metric is performing those
are dimensional concerns and that
dimensional metadata is what we hang on
these on these nodes
and that is basically it right uh Fun
and Profit and four easy steps uh we uh
you know we start the door star we
decompose into inputs uh we layer on
additional inputs and we hang that
metadata inputs uh now again we're not
going to talk so much about the
ratification of a growth model here what
we are going to talk about is beating
you over the heads so that you're
excited because this is not extremely
complicated what's complicated is
getting the activation energy to
actually go do this so we're going to
get you all fired up and we're going to
talk about applications and use cases uh
once you have this assuming you have a
magical growth model assuming you've
done this exercise I'm going to talk a
little bit about how I've used this
stuff
so applications and extensions
application number one onboarding so uh
Robert E was up here some of you heard
us talk early today um Robert E uh said
a lot of things about how to be a 10x
analyst uh one of those things is uh
domain context right how do you get
domain context I know of no better way
to facilitate the transfer of domain
context and to First Express that tacit
context into a metric tree and share
that metric period Folks at you on board
at a company called hustle we would do
this we did this for every data
scientist every data analyst every data
engineer we cut onboarding time into an
hour and it was so successful that this
is how the entire company started
onboarding their functions right the
marketers would onboard product
marketers by understanding the by by
sharing with them the metric tree for
marketing same with sales same with
product same with what have you same
with all these other functions utterly
transformational
uh number two as a gateway to a
knowledge repo so uh at a uh you know at
a company called keep where I was
running growth and data one of our
struggles was uh a struggle that made
probably many of you are familiar with
which is we do all of this analysis we
do all this experimentation we put into
a notebook and it never sees the light
of day right no one ever talked about it
again uh the that challenge was real for
us too uh the way we went about solving
that problem was to actually uh put the
to shelve all the analyzes all the
experimentation behind a metric tray and
to make the metric tree the primary
interface so what we did there was we uh
yeah I mentioned this metadata that we
had around uh uh confidence and strength
so we would create this Dynamic
interface for a metric tree we would
expose it to everyone in the company uh
where uh the color codes here that you
see represented strength so was this
metric uh you know red yellow green
strong weak or you know kind of a
middling relationship the uh the dashed
lines the weight here that you see on
relationships represents confidence so
how certain are we in this case we're
not so sure uh we're very sure that
speed delete is a week is a medium
influence we're not so sure that AE
tenure is a strong influence we have
some kind of weak certainty around it we
have some experimentation around it and
everything that we did on data and
growth every experiment that was done in
the company was behind one of these
lines in one of these nodes all the
analysis all the experimentation was
behind one of these uh one of these
relationships and it was very
transparent where do we have confidence
where do we not where do we need to go
where do we need to experiment where did
we experiment recently uh and this led
to like 800 Improvement in engagement
with the artifacts that data science was
producing
uh that lends naturally into uh the next
utterly transformational use case which
is as a mission statement for data teams
uh so when I run data teams uh I have
data on growth themes I have them look
at this and tell them that their mandate
is oriented purely towards the levers
they're mandate as a data team is to
turn those uh unsolid lines solid to use
experimentation analysis to turn those
uh you know low confidence relationships
into high conference relationships and
your mandate as a data person is to turn
uh is to light up the board to light up
the tree with more levers because
ultimately data's responsibility is to
identify growth levers and operators
responsibility is to pull those growth
levers this is a completely
transformational utterly
transformational way to position a data
team if you actually position your data
team like this you will never again have
conversations about does my data team
create value how much value does my data
stream create how should I measure the
value because the value is the process
and the process is identify levers that
Traders can pull them and if operators
are able to pull levers effectively
you've done your job
uh another use case is dashboarding so
when I joined flexboard there were 2700
dashboards uh and there were 600 people
in the company so that's a you know
several dashboards per person uh the way
we cut that down to 51 dashboards uh was
by building Metra tree first and by
partitioning dashboards based on limbs
of the tree right you start by
understanding the structure of your
business and you start breaking out the
limbs of your tree and you start
partitioning those into dashboards and
those dashboards now have kind of
inherent structure
and they have relative structure right
the structure of the dashboard
internally makes sense but they also
make sense from One dashboard to another
because these dashboards now have this
logical hierarchy to them that's derived
from the tree
and we were able to cut from 2700 to 51
in a matter of a couple months as a
result
business reviews so Katie Bauer was up
here earlier today and she was talking
about business reviews and uh look I've
run business reviews of dozens of
companies I know of more no more
effective way to run a business review
than off of a metric tree uh we anchor
on the Business Review we anchor on the
dashboard sorry on the business on the
metric tray we anchor on the metric tree
we look at what's red and we only drill
on the Reds and it's very transparent
right it's very transparent when
customers is down where we need to be
focusing our investigation leads win
rate in this case speed the lead
uh the natural uh complement to that is
root cause analysis so Katie talked
about a lot of the failure points of
business reviews and some of these are
you know that these teams are inundated
with questions these they're inundated
uh with these async offline root cause
analyzes but look root cause analyzes is
Trivial root cause analysis can actually
be automated because any deviation in an
output metric is really just a function
of either dimensional shift or input
shift and if we've actually hung the
dimensions we've actually specified the
ontology if we've actually specify the
relationships here if we take that time
do that up front root cause analysis is
now Cakewalk right root cause analysis
is now automated and that's that's
possible and that's what we were able to
do at flexboard for instance
um the flip side of root cause analysis
is forecasting right if you can go down
the tree to do recognize analysis you
can just go up the tree to do
forecasting and forecasting is now just
a matter of taking those inputs
understanding what the drivers are those
of those inputs simulating changes in
those inputs and then you end up with
forecasting utterly transformational
so uh I see lots of jazzed up faces
everyone has the activation energy to go
forth and prosper
um so uh so look I'm very animated about
this
um I think uh we have too many data
people we should fire at least 75 of
them and we can if we have magic trees
uh no um I I'm very excited about the
possibility of what metric trees can do
and so one of the things that I've been
really focused on is how do we make it
easy uh and for the past six months I've
been working on a variety of ways to try
and make this easier try and lower the
activation energy required to be able to
actually make this work in companies
uh so there are there's a lot to talk
about here again around how you rarify
the growth model uh we are just going to
talk about solving uh two of the
problems uh uh that uh stand in the way
of people being able to implement this
effectively and those are both around
metrics uh problem number one is what
should my metrics be in the first place
right because your stakeholders probably
don't know uh you may not know how do
you actually go about constructing a
tree and what do you hang on the tree
the second is uh great I have metrics
but now how do I actually produce those
metrics right because if I'm going to do
all this automated root cause analysis
and forecasting I have to go beyond a
logical model and I have to go to
something physical that actually
persists these metrics so how do we
solve this metric problem on both sides
how do we understand what metrics to
have and how do we actually produce
those metrics so that's one of the
problems I'm focused on solving and uh
the way I think about solving that
company and trying to enable more
companies right now is by recognizing
that businesses aren't snowflakes this
is a fundamental thesis of mine that by
and large you know everything that we're
talking about about this metrics Tree by
and large that metric straight and the
variance and the metrics tree is
explained by business model for the
purposes of Metro and this is a broader
statement too for the purposes of
analytics internal facing data science
all metrics all dashboards 90 can be
standardized based on are you B2B are
you B to C are you e-commerce are you
Marketplace because B2B is B2B B2B SAS
B2B SAS is B2B SAS inherently and in
recognition of this one of the things
that I've been working on is what I call
Soma so Soma is a standard operating
metrics and analytics and this is a
project I've been working on for a
couple of months now where uh for each
of a set of business models uh starting
with you know B2B SAS which is what
we're looking at here uh identifying
what are the spanning set of metrics
that matter to BW SAS and the case of
bdb SAS and or this business model we've
identified about 250 and for those
metrics uh looking across you know
Decades of experience looking across
hundreds of other companies that we're
talking to uh what is the key metadata
that is necessary for this metric uh how
is the metric defined what are the
related metrics uh what are the kind of
Dimensions that we should generally
slice by what are the periods we should
we should look at when we're when we're
producing this metric so this is step
one right can we understand what the
metrics are for a given business model
and can we understand what their
interrelationships are because if we can
standardize what the metrics are I can
also tell you what the relationships are
because I've done the trees many many
times right so can we standardize what
these metrics are and what the
relationships are what those nodes and
edges are right
uh this uh is a this is a completely
open source project I have no interest
in commercially activating this project
this is something I'm uh depending on I
think there's going to be online people
that are watching this too depending on
when you watch this it'll be in some
state of development but right now
currently it's on selmastandard.com
which I think points to a GitHub page
right now I'll point it to this website
uh later this later this evening and uh
we are starting by releasing uh uh just
growth accounting metrics which is a set
of about 20 to 30 metrics and slowly
will expand from there to represent the
full Corpus of first B2B SAS metrics and
then other metrics across other business
models as well now that solves only one
problem that solves the how do I build a
tree what metrics do I put on the tree
problem there is another problem too
which is how do I actually construct
those metrics in a low friction way uh
part of the Selma standard project is
also to automate the construction of
those metrics we've defined the metrics
we'll also automate the construction of
those metrics through DBT scripts
provided that you can map your data and
so what we also have here is uh what you
may be able to see on the screen is this
notion of activities in the Soma
standard we envision a business as
basically just a set of activities
instead of thinking about a business as
a bunch of tables we should actually
Envision businesses as basically a
ledger of things that happen in the
business things that the company does
and things that customers do in the
business what we are specifying in the
standard is if you raise these events if
you raise these this Ledger of
activities that a business does we'll
take it from there and we'll automate
the generation of these metrics so this
is a work in progress something I'm very
excited about again completely commuter
driven open source to try and make it
easier for more data teams to get at
that real Mandate of how do we build
these growth models
uh so that's that's about it we there's
a lot we didn't cover
um how do we actually reify this growth
model uh maybe I'll be able to answer
some of those questions how do we
actually build this how do we make this
interactive how did you do all those use
cases how did you convince uh you know
the company to see the world this way
how do I use the standard how do I get
these use cases to work uh there will be
an active conversation I think to start
uh you know would love for folks to
check out the standard as it evolves
over the coming weeks
um you know we have a lot planned to
release over the next week or two
um follow us on Twitter uh my partner on
this work is ergo shablati also on data
Twitter uh so I think follow both of us
you know we're going to continue an
active conversation and we'd love for
you to be a part of it uh because again
I think uh to borrow a word I used
earlier uh utterly transformational if
you can Orient towards these kind of
standard metrics so I think that's it
folks
thank you